[Musique]
unissent donc on va parler de la
préparation c'est donc entre guillemets
le coup du siècle que vous aviez préparé
à 5 chacun 20 rôle précis et la cible
était identifié la star internationale
kim kardashian saviez qu'il était kim
kardashian moi du tout pas du tout quoi
je ne sais pas du tout ah ouais donc je
ne savais rien des je savais la famille
kardashian c'est les séries que je n'ai
jamais regardé d'accord donc vous saviez
pas du tout qui s'était auto pourquoi
est ce que vous l'avez choisi l appât
elle s'est sentie avant qu'on a choisi
c'est son diamant je crois vous avez
vous avez eu une info pas il était sur
internet a toutefois c'est pas moi qui
le dis mais comment on est venu vous
voir pour vous parler de cette affaire
en cdd des connaissances et des
connaissances qui vous ont dit quoi dont
10 étaient intéressés une opération kavo
diamant dans un car on sait tout de
suite que ça vaut 400 ça dépend de la
couleur 4 5 6 millions d'euros donc là
on s'y intéresse parce que des acteurs
vous prenez 4 millions n'a pas alors le
soir on vous décidé d'agir et donc
seulement cet hôtel parisien de luxe
il y à un veilleur de nuit mais son
garde du corps est avec sa soeur en
boîte de nuit
oui c'est normal au regard du goéland
raccompagner chez elle il avait besoin
de rester il s'en va ça enfermée chez
elle
surtout à l'hôtel ils disent et c'est
secure bah oui normalement les pas
besoin qu'il reste c'est serré si
l'intéressé 16h pas été normal alors
vous le saviez tout sympa elle avait une
si faible protection
vous savez qu'il n'était plus là à
boutte vous allez on attendait ce moment
là bien sûr on sait qu'on a été relevé à
2 heures du matin donc le cambriolage
vous avez donc dans cet hôtel a billion
faux policiers alors non on rentre pas
en fonte position rendant vététistes
d'accord tranquillement donc le soir
comme ça vous fait du vtt avec un gilet
réfléchissant moi j'avais ans je les
avais un réfléchissantes jours donc
l'hôtel y étaient fermés ou bien
vous avez d'abord sur la route est
ouverte au sein on s'en était assurée
aussi elle était ouverte
d'accord vous rentrez et vous faites
quoi non sous le porche
il ya deux caméras en eau ouais on avait
apporté de quoi les camoufler mais on
s'est aperçu que c'était trop ton
pourrait pas le faire d'accord donc là
vous arrivez en bété titre claque est
gouverneur alors on s'habille en on est
trois d'abord d'accord on s'habille avec
des cacahuètes policiers casquette de
policier mais des produits de cinéma on
a mis ça on a mis en nous moi je me suis
fait voler mon collègue des cagoules et
le troisième est resté le visage
découvert et il a frappé à la porte et
la conscience police police ouvrez
ouvrez tu as dit oui j'ai bien japon
c'est d'accord au concierge et lille a
ouvert la porte a dit vous venez pour à
dreuz vous venez pour la droite
bah oui c'est un nombre inconnu pour ça
aussi et donc donc ici c'est plié aurait
il s'est laissé faire il a pas discuté
pendant qu'on discutait nous ont
entourés
bon j'ai attrapé le bras je les couche
et j'ai fait un petit balayette j'ai
envoyé par terre bon là je me suis
retourné sur lui j'ai attaché à voter
oui c'est bon c'est lui qui l'a plaqué
au sol et qui lui a mis je crois faut
pas rigoler oui mais je rigole pas du
tout simplement c'est ça qui la
trahissent et l'adn qui avait sur ses
bras ses moyens non en fait c'est pas le
mieux votre adn qui avait été dans le
hold up en belgique et le béa il vous a
retrouvé comme ça c'est ce que vous
dites dans le livre en tout cas comment
ce qu'est ce qu'ils sont que quand on a
immobilisé le concierge mes deux
collègues allemands l'ont pris sont
venus demander la clé la chambre il nous
a tout donné à quelqu'un normal il a
tout donné il a accompagné mes collègues
et moi je reste en bas à la place à la
réception pour vale porte recevoir les
gens si quelqu'un venait alors donc là
vos complices ils ont la clé y rentre
dans la chambre de kim kardashian et
rentrer dans l'argent du carrelage ans
donc ce que le compte rendu qu'on va
faire après sûr c'est que ayons pris son
téléphone était un téléphone elle avait
une espèce de voile sur elle elle était
assise en tailleur a le téléphone a été
tout seul elle était toute seule donc la
halle à hillion 10 de l'eau y compris la
balle était posé sur le
bord du lit sur le cheveu ou alors a
donné la bague n'a pas résisté à la
donne et ses bijoux son coffre à bijoux
d'accord ils ont pris un élan ratifiant
attaché les mains avec du scotch et
l'ont jeté sur le sur le lit ils ont
laissé sur le lit son parti si elle
avait reçu la bague diamant pour 9
millions d'euros nuit non mais je dis
bien la bague plus son talent du jeune
et bien sûr donc 9 millions d'euros de
butin
mais tu les bijoux n'était pas n'étaient
pas les siens d'accord mais quand même
donc pendant ce temps la voix grave et
la responsable des actes on est en bas
vous fait le guet donc c'est ça on fait
le guet ça a duré 7 est très rapide
je crois qu'on aurait moins 10 minutes
entre 7 et 8 minutes ne restait que vous
allez finalement furent avec le butin à
vélo oui c'est vous qui transportait des
bijoux une partie à part la bague qui
est dans un sac qui ne ferme pas c'est
sa seule inverse mais bon voilà break et
qu'est ce qu'ils deviennent des bijoux
ce que les bijoux ils ont toujours pas
été retrouvé ah non moi elles seront par
contre mais ils ont été vendus tout de
suite à une chose qu'on met à l'abri
c'est une buse en a toujours
en partant vous croisez une voiture de
police et enfin voila vous dit que c'est
fini je pense que c'est cuit pour ma
part pour moi et ça qu'à un moment vous
tombez et vous fait tomber des bijoux
dans le caniveau
comme j'avais vu la voiture de police
avec le sac fermé pas et que je tenais
je tenais avec le guidon d'accord ça m'a
déconcentré
j'ai survécu désirs d'avenir à tunis
elle arrive à la rivale arrive puis
finalement elle n'est pas venue et le
temps que j'en prenne les esprits le sac
s'est pris dans la roue avant j'ai fait
rouler bouler lendemain vous êtes sur
toutes les télés du monde entier
qu'est-ce que vous êtes dit à ce moment
là vous avez été surmontées par un
violent fait une grosse connerie fallait
pas y toucher
ça vous allez y on a fait une grosse
connerie est-ce que vous avez un message
à dire à kim kardashian elle peut très
bien la voir oui est-ce que vous avez un
message
alors ça sera le même que j'ai déjà
donné dans plusieurs interviews à savoir
que je lui demande de me pardonner
je m'excuse si elle peut pardonner ce
qu'elle était traumatisée a bien sûr
elle ressentit qu'elle a vécu c'est
parce que j'avais vu la personne à
touchable quelles étaient ses 5 alors
que son petit kim kardashian n'importe
quelle personne c'est extrêmement
traumatisant et bien sûr mais bien
d'abord qu'est ce que vous avez lu dire
encore une fois je vous demande pas de
me pardonner si elle accepte si elle le
veut si elle ne veut pas vivre avec
comme j'ai toujours vécu avec j'ai
personnellement je bonne réussite
qu'elle continue sa carrière tant mieux
pour elle
j'ai rien contre a le cerveau elle me
charger un peu me charger sa zone des
charges a fait ce qu'elle veut